VERY LITTLE IN THE OVAL OFFICE
OR THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE WILL HAVE MORE OF MY
MONOLOGUE COMING UP FIRST.
JOINING US IN OUR FORMER
WHITE HOUSE CHIEFS OF STAFF
BRAINS PREVIOUS AND MARK MEADOWS
ALONG WITH FORMER ARKANSAS
GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE.
YOU WERE IN THE ROOM, YOU WERE
THERE AS REINCE PRIEBUS WAS WITH
PRESIDENT XI.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT YOU ARE READING AND SEEING
HOW AND WHAT IT WAS LIKE WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT?
>> IT'S A POSITION OF WEAKNESS.
HE MENTIONED IT IN YOUR
MONOLOGUE.
THERE'S TWO WORDS THAT DEFINE
THIS PRESIDENCY RIGHT NOW.
THE OTHER IS DESPERATION.
IT'S TO TAKE FOCUS OFF OF
JOE BIDEN'S INEPT POLICIES THAT
CONTINUE TO HAUNT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHETHER IT'S CHINA, AND YOU'VE
BEEN ONE OF THE FEW THAT HAVE
BEEN CONSISTENTLY TALKING ABOUT
THE DEBACLE IN AFGHANISTAN THAT
CAUSED 13 AMERICAN SERVICE
MEMBERS THEIR LIVES, BUT
CANDIDLY COMMITS THAT WEAKNESS
THAT GOES ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
JOE BIDEN HAS A KNOCK ON WOOD
KIND OF STRATEGY AND HOPE FOR
THE BEST AND IT IS NOT GIVING
AMERICANS THE BEST.
>> Sean: REINCE PRIEBUS, I
THINK YOU WERE THERE WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP ACTUALLY HAD
PRESIDENT XI AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
AM I WRONG ABOUT THAT?
>> ACTUALLY I CAN ANSWER THIS.
I WAS AT THE MEETING IN
MAR-A-LAGO WHEN PRESIDENT XI
CAME TO MAR-A-LAGO AND WE WERE
HAVING DINNER.
I SAT ACROSS THE TABLE FROM
PRESIDENT XI AND I WAS SITTING
NEXT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ONE THING REMARKABLE THAT THIS
DINNER THERE WERE TWO TOPICS
THAT PRESIDENT XI WENT ON
30 MINUTES STRAIGHT WITHOUT
STOPPING ON.
NUMBER ONE WAS THE HISTORY OF
CHINA AND JAPAN.
AND NUMBER TWO WAS TAIWAN, AND
PRESIDENT XI WENT ON AND ON AND
ON ABOUT THE STRATEGIC
IMPORTANCE OF TAIWAN, MAKING IT
CLEAR THEY DIDN'T WANT US
MESSING WITH TAIWAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AFTER DINNER
SAID EXCUSE ME, HAVE AN
EMERGENCY, I WILL BE RIGHT BACK,
LEFT THE DINNER TABLE, WENT DOWN
TO A PRIVATE ROOM, SAT DOWN AND
LAUNCHED 59 CRUISE MISSILES, HOW
WAS THE CREME BRULEE?
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
JOE BIDEN AND DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: I'VE HEARD THAT STORY
SO I KNOW FOR FACT THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S BEEN CONFIRMED BY A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE, THESE ARE
SIMPLE YET DEEPLY PROFOUND
PRINCIPLES, STRENGTH RATHER THAN
WEAKNESS.
IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THE HOSTILE
REGIMES, THEY SENSE WEAKNESS AND
THEY ARE ALL TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
IT.
>> WE'VE ALL SEEN THIS MOVIE
BEFORE.
JOE BIDEN IS McFLY AND BIFF IS
GETTING THE BEST OF THEM EVERY
TIME.
IT IS A THREAT TO THE WHOLE
WORLD BECAUSE THESE DICTATORS
AND OPPORTUNIST SCENE OPENING.
THEY WATCH WHAT HAPPENS WITH
BIDEN, THEY KNOW THAT HE IS
COMPROMISED IN TERMS OF HOW MANY
BUSINESS DEALS HIS SON AND
PROBABLY HE HAS HAD WITH CHINA
AND BIDEN IS RUNNING WITH IT AND
IT REALLY SHOULD BE A MAJOR
CONCERN TO MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
I'M GLAD NANCY PELOSI WENT TO
TAIWAN.
I'M GLAD SOMEONE IS SAYING TO
CHINA, WE WILL DO WHAT WE
DOGGONE WANT TO.
WE DON'T TAKE ORDERS FROM YOU.
I WISH BIDEN HAD STOOD WITH HER.
FOR THE RECORD, YOU ARE NOT
OFTEN GOING TO HEAR ME SAY NICE
THINGS ABOUT NANCY PELOSI BUT ON
THIS WEEK'S --
>> Sean: GOVERNOR, SHE DIDN'T
HAVE A CHOICE.
ONCE THEY THREATENED --
>> NO, SHE DIDN'T.
>> Sean: IN MY VIEW, SHE
DIDN'T HAVE A CHOICE.
I DON'T THINK I'M A
MARK MEADOWS, I DON'T SEE ANY
SCENARIO WHAT CHINA IS SAYING,
REUNIFICATION WITH TAIWAN
DOESN'T TAKE PLACE AND FRANKLY I
DON'T SEE ANY SOLUTION TO
GETTING BRITTNEY GRINER HOME.
THAT'S AN AMERICAN CITIZEN THAT
DOES NOT BELONG IN JAIL FOR NINE
YEARS AND OFFERING THIS MASTER
OF DEATH IN EXCHANGE, YOU
COULDN'T HAVE A MORE ONE-SIDED
DEAL IN FAITH OF PUTIN AND HE IS
STILL REJECTING IT.
>> HE IS STILL REJECTING IT BUT
IT GOES BACK TO THE THEME, IT'S
THE WEAKNESS YOU DIDN'T SEE
UNDER DONALD TRUMP AND YOU'RE
SEEING EACH AND EVERY DAY, WHEN
THEY SMELL WEAKNESS, THEY ARE A
LOT MORE AGGRESSIVE, A NINE YEAR
SENTENCE IS SAD.
WE WANT HER TO COME HOME BUT NOW
WE ARE TRADING HER FOR A
PRISONER THAT WAS ACTUALLY
CONVICTED OF CONSPIRACY WHO
KILLED AMERICAN CITIZENS.
IT SETS A VERY BAD PRECEDENT.
I CAN TELL YOU, DONALD TRUMP IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WAS ABLE TO GET
MORE HOSTAGES RELEASED AND BACK
HOME WITHOUT HAVING TO PAY THE
PRICE.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE LEADERS KNEW HE WAS
STRONG AND HE WAS WILLING TO
BACK IT UP.
>> Sean: LET'S STAY ON THAT
THEME BECAUSE THIS IS THE
DIFFERENCE, THE TALIBAN DIDN'T
KILL AN AMERICAN FOR THE LAST 18
MONTHS OF TRUMP'S PRESIDENCY.
DIDN'T SEE NORTH KOREA.
ALL DONALD TRUMP EVERY GAME
KIM JONG UN WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME, THAT'S IT.
AND WE GOT A LOT OF CONCESSIONS
FROM NORTH KOREA AS A RESULT.
YOU DIDN'T SEE THESE HOSTILITIES
FROM RUSSIA OR CHINA SO WHAT IS
THE DIFFERENCE HERE?
IS IT THAT THEY SEE WEAKNESS
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IT?
>> ALBERT EINSTEIN HAD A
FAVORITE CHOICE THAT WEAKNESS OF
ATTITUDE IS WEAKNESS OF
CHARACTER.
SO WHEN YOU START DAY ONE
DESTROYING YOUR BORDER, MAKING
YOUR COUNTRY NOT ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AGAIN.
WHEN YOU QUOTED THE SECOND HALF
OF REAGAN'S QUOTE, PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH AND WEAKNESS INVITES
AGGRESSION AND IT'S TRUE.
IT STARTED ON DAY ONE, IT
CONTINUED TO THE ECONOMY TO FUEL
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AND NOW HE'S
DESPERATE ON THIS
BRITTNEY GRINER ISSUE AND BY THE
WAY, THE OTHER PIECE OF THIS,
THE FACT THAT JOE BIDEN WAS
UPSTAGED BY HIS OWN SPEAKER AND
THE SPEAKER DIDN'T LISTEN TO
JOE BIDEN, YET AGAIN WITHIN HIS
OWN PARTY, THEY'RE WALKING AWAY
FROM HIM ON 2024, IT IS WEAKNESS
ALL THE WAY FROM DAY ONE AND I
WAS ON PARTIES ABANDONING HIM.
>> Sean: DO YOU SEE ANY
SCENARIO UNDER WHICH JOE BIDEN
WOULD SHOCK US ALL IN STAND UP
TO RUSSIA OR CHINA?
BECAUSE I DO NOT.
>> WE ARE NOT SEEING IT, HE'S
BEEN IN OFFICE FOR TWO YEARS AND
HE CERTAINLY HASN'T GIVEN THAT
KIND OF IMPRESSION AND IF HE IS
GOING TO DO IT THERE NEVER HAS
BEEN A BETTER TIME THAN THIS
WEEK AND HE HAS FAILED TO DO IT.
AND JOHN KIRBY CAN DEFEND HIM
ALL HE WANTS TO BUT TO SAY THAT
JOE BIDEN WAS SO BUSY HE DIDN'T
HAVE OPPORTUNITY OR TIME TO PICK
UP THE PHONE AND TO SAY
SOMETHING TO PRESIDENT XI IS
ABSURD.
UTTERLY ABSURD.
WHAT WAS HE DOING, ORDERING
ICE CREAM FOR TAKE-OUT?
WHAT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
TRYING TO KEEP CHINA FROM
INVADING AND TAKING OVER TAIWAN
RIGHT NOW